au pub the good things in toile
la blague tombe mal car je ne suis pas
bilingue à revenir dans la première
vidéo de 2019 la première que je tourne
en 2019 pour la chaîne youtube et rien
n'a changé j'ai le même t-shirt qui pue
et la même chaise
[Musique]
quoi de mieux pour commencer l'année
qu'une vidéo travailler sur un spread de
bitche et des vidéos sur les retraites
vous m'en voyez pas mal de ce raid ready
2 par mail et je suis content je
découvre plein de trucs parce que savoir
qui en a énormément qui parle de tous
les sujets alors vous avez très bien
compris que ce qui m'intéresse pour les
vidéos c'est des trucs un peu qu'on
emploie un peu drôle mais y en a plein
qui sont pas spécialement drôle ils sont
juste d'être coûte apprend des choses
sur je sais pas moi sur la politique les
lois les derniers pas de boss dans tel
ou tel pays il est enfin bref je vous
dit tout et n'importe quoi mais on
apprend plein de trucs en resterait dit
non je dis ça parce que moi j'ai l'air
d'un gros coup à faire que les
laisserait drôle l'assuré dit mais y'a
plein de trucs cool c'est qu'on en fera
un jour d'ailleurs certains coûts les
moins drôles en vidéo pourquoi pas mais
aujourd'hui on veut bien commencer
l'année on veut sourire essoufflé du nez
et quoi de mieux pour cela que le thread
c'est son nom
vraiment il s'appelle nous pourquoi il
s'appelle comme ça parce que c'est que
des photos qui te font réfléchir ou
quand tu regard au premier coup d'oeil à
un truc que tu as pas vu ou alors quand
tu gagnes un truc où tu réalises quelque
chose qui va pas dans la photo fin bref
c'est très sympathique très rigolo on va
passer un bon moment convivial vous et
moi le premier 2019 et j'espère qu'il
sera mémorable
excusez moi je suis très heureux de
faire une vidéo ça fait très longtemps
et ça m'a un peu manquée quoi tu vois la
tête
allez on y va premier poste non mais le
fameux on l'a vu dans le truck tik tok
la mecque cette carte et les
surpuissante gros elle change le sens
des choses tu peux tout renvoyer avec ça
les insultes un licenciement tout je
pense super mais peut-être que je
m'enflamme monsieur macron qu'il
faudrait interdire cette carte son
pouvoir est sous côté on passe à la
suivante
il transporte une soucoupe oui il a des
lunettes de jeu d'alien oui
il s'agit bien évidemment d'un montage
de toutes pièces ayant pour but de faire
rire et de divertir une communauté
réside bien évidemment nous ça ne nous a
pas trop à temps on va pas se mentir
j'ai compris pendant monde tweaks vous
n'avez pas honte
les sachets font la même taille pourquoi
le blanc est plus petit que le noir
quel message avez vous essayé de faire
passer à travers votre produit quel
message tweet c'est scandaleux et je
n'ai pas ça parce que je suis le blanc
macbett d'idées c'est une belle idée
c'est vrai est obligatoire voilà devrait
y avoir une loi sur ça on doit tous
avoir un petit triangle et un gilet
jaune là dans le coffre la auquel on
tombe en panne bord devrait avoir sa
lavande dockett cet avertissement est
trop proche de la voiture c'est amorti
le choc si tu lui est rentré dedans
c'est tout bénef bon et quand vous
marchez dans la rue à ce bruit là tout
le temps mais que j'ai même pas vu je
n'ai il a volé la salière hammami
beaucoup mais quand vrai l'idée géniale
parce que psychologiquement ton
adversaire est déstabilisé c'est sûr bon
et si en plus tu joues en mangeant ça a
son utilité ne sais pas du tout ça
devrait aller dans leur ai dit oui
ben mec j'espère que mes enceintes
avaient un parapluie mona lisa prend le
bus line 57
elle est comme nous on assure coutelas
les touristes y viennent de partout dans
le monde pour l'avoir lapin mais n'ouvre
les français on la voit dans le bus mon
pote au la mecque c'est incroyable elle
est sortie du tableau on a vérifié au
look si elle est encore dans le tableau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça sympa base un moment tranquille
absolument absurde mais terriblement
efficace je dois l'admettre
[Musique]
quel gamin à vous et tous disent à quel
gamin mais qu'est-ce qu'il a raison
c'est drôle pour nous aux rôles mais
quand lui dans des années il repensera à
ces moments-là en cours au lieu de
travail et il a fait le coup il a fait
le zigoto a dessiné ses preuves sur
paint et qu'à cause de ça il a raté son
diplôme et qui n'a pas eu le travail de
ses rêves et qui n'est pas content de
son quotidien cinq ans après quand il se
rendra compte de tout ça il va regretter
d'avoir dessiné un moustachu à binocles
ok je pense que j'ai là c'est la rentrée
ça me réussit pas du tout c'est génial
ce moment où tu crois qu'il n'y a rien
et d'un coup tu comprends qu'il y a tout
en fait
bien évidemment le poteau était
probablement cassé cette déduction ne
peut pas nous échapper quand même pas se
mentir
mais attention si vous passez devant un
restaurant thaïlandais à ne pas vous
asseoir en plus un en france je regarde
cette vidéo
bisous à toi on espère mais évidemment
qu'il n'y avait pas le dessus du poteau
oh oh non moi j'ai jamais réussi à voler
le nez ça marche avec les statuts en
fait c'est un truc de statuts très
amusant très efficace il dit pas ça
parce que ma grand-mère s'amuser à faire
ses blagues tout le temps quand j'étais
petit il est évident que c'est un fake
mais je dois l'admettre de ses
emballages avoue tu as envie de lâcher
son meilleur
ça me fatigue en cette vidéo elle
fatigue
non ce n'est pas de l'humour qui vous
fatigue ça ça me détruit j'étais bien
j'étais en forme maintenant je suis
fatigué après cette image là à salles
d'angles au plus on passe plus ses
globes avec ses incroyables mais non
mais quelle idée de merde mais kelly
zizanie mais je n'ai pas d'autres mecs
quand j'ai regardé breaking bad ya
longtemps j'ai bloqué sur sa sur la
ressemblance entre ce mec
et ce mec il n'y en a aucune pourtant
aucune attendait mais c'est mais c'est
outre en mai ya un nombre de choses ou
trois dans cette vidéo mais on commence
très mal 2009
ils sont si innocent ne comprennent pas
du tout confiance et photos on va les
prendre pour des gros [ __ ] c'est
horrible gros ça me fait mal aux doigts
et bat pour les doigts d'encaisser que
ça c'est pas un truc là s'est passé un
truc alors affiché des tests pour
daltoniens dans le fond de la boutique
[Musique]
le mec mais faites attention quand vous
êtes des costumes comme ça vous pouvez
traumatisé une famille entière surtout
qu'il n'avait pas du tout l'air heureux
dans tes bras ce moment je comprends
pourquoi
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mec je les ai pas je n'ai pas ça me rend
fou je ne l'est pas ce sentiment 2 de
faiblesse et d'être à côté de la plaque
ah ok ah je le vois pas parce que je
suis daltonien mec qui dit un
commentaire aux mecs jupons j'écoute je
devenais un gros coup en fait la vanne
ne vous le voyez vous de prendre pour un
con c'est qu'ils ont le même la même
couleur d'élèves les deux là et ça veut
dire qu'ils se sont embrassés mais elle
pose avec lui en mode c'est lui son
petit ami mais on sait qu'elle a
embrassé lui puisqu'ils ont la même
couleur d'élèves à bâgé faire une
émission où j'expliquais de la guerre
pour l'école comme moi allez on y va à
mec je me milan à comprendre ça m'a
rendu fou peu tard elle n'est pas
supposé du tout regardé la caméra dans
le reflet éloigne-toi enfants maudits à
se serait dit me remue on passe par
toutes les émotions
écoutez si pas un meilleur moment comme
ça laissez-le on rigole dans 15 ans on
sera tous comme des cons comme ça vous
allez voir errigo longtemps qu'on peut
wop pow pow pow on va voir si vous avez
révisé l'avant 2019 si vous êtes prêts à
regarder les vidéos 2019 comment ça
s'appelle ça 1 réponse à la paralyse au
lit réponse b l'appareil dolly répond
c'est le doliprane à la
ça c'est les élèves ça ça c'est mes
élèves ça n'en fait pas on va faire un
bon deuxième trimestre ensemble comment
peuvent-ils planter le drapeau américain
sur la lune si on voit la lune de là où
ils sont si sexy
j'imagine à la place de la fille avec
cette scène soit vrai l'enfer le
cauchemar arrêter là il ya même plus de
bahia juste décrié de l'étonnement la et
du scandale arrêté ne me fais pas une bd
avec tourmente
[Musique]
avec mais ça me fait trop calqué dessin
c'est hyper drôle cette vanne ne pas
faire du tout ce qui est prévu c'est si
bon
ouah ouah pas papa il s'est passé quoi
la non non non non non non non non or
rien et je vais dire un mot je vais dire
un mot et vous allez fermer la vidéo
conjonctivite et bien nous voilà arrivés
au bout de ce thread j'espère que vous
avez beaucoup et c'est un verbe que nous
venons d'inventer ensemble ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais pas traîné sur
édité mec c'est un vrai réseau social je
le sais parce que je commence à être
accro c'est pas bien du tout n'hésitez
pas et même de ciel vous a plu comme
d'habitude si les slate vous plaît pour
cette année il y aura probablement
quelques nouvelles sortes de vidéos qui
apparaîtront dans le même esprit qu'est
ce que je fais la crise raid etc alors
certes un peu trouvé ça facile mais
franchement je skie faire ça même c'est
simple je m'en fous je passe un bon
moment ça me fait marrer les codes
d'humour que les ces images là on en
fait c'est vraiment le la culture web et
je trouve ça cool de faire des vidéos là
dessus j'aimerais bien aussi parlé un
petit peu des buzz de france et tous qui
a bref j'ai pas mal d'idées comme ça un
peu en mode tokyo à faire cette année je
trouve ça je trouve ça cool ça a changé
un peu de ce qu'on a fait l'année
dernière en tout cas je vous fais plein
de gros bisous d'ailleurs je vais aussi
changer ce décor là dans deux trois
vidéos il aura complètement changé comme
ce sera aussi l'occasion de faire des
nouveaux formats de vidéo je vais tenter
du tout je me faire plusieurs comme
l'année dernière voilà sortir de sa zone
de confort ce faire qu'il fait sa
musique c'est le plus important pour
cette année je l'avais déjà dit merci
d'avoir regardé ça n'oubliez pas si vous
voyez une photo vous ne comprenez pas
tout il sait pas à lâcher votre meilleur
ça me fera plaisir je vous dis à bientôt
de sa prochaine vidéo n'hésitez pas à
m'envoyer par mail des threads cool de
ré dit y a des trucs même pas forcément
des trucs qu'on en abuse trucs
intelligents des trucs cool qu'ils
apprennent des choses n'hésitez pas à
m'envoyer j'en ai pas mal là que j'ai
repéré dont je vais vous parler mais bon
si jamais peut-être que je peux passer à
côté de certains je dis à bientôt dans
une prochaine vidéo et j'ai hâte que des
gorges changea de vous montrer le
prochain décor il va être très sympa je
fais une vidéo cette table pour
l'occasion bisous tout le monde
[Musique]